how many times has loki actually died
and does it count if it's a loki from an
alternate reality how about an alligator
all mcu fans know the god of mischief
has been through a lot here's loki's
timeline explained
loki was born on jotunheim as loki
laufen child of the frost giant king but
throughout most of loki's upbringing the
truth of his lineage was hidden from him
and he was raised as odin's own son loki
began to question his parentage as he
got older however and finally confronted
odin by asking him directly where he
came from
odin revealed that centuries prior he
led the asgardians into battle against
laufey's forces and ultimately prevailed
in defeat however laufey abandoned his
child odin took the little one in and
raised him as his own he hoped that one
day loki's dual parentage might help
unite the two rival realms with loki
taking his birth father's place as king
of jotenheim while still being loyal to
odin
if i do then what
it would be a long time before loki
truly understood his origins and his
father's love for him
though we've not seen much of loki's
youth on asgard we do know he and his
brother had a contentious relationship
loki's penchant for mischief emerged
early on in the madcap thor ragnarok we
learn of several of his childhood antics
including the time he turned himself
into a snake to bait his brother into a
vicious stabbing we were eight at the
time
thor wasn't without his own wicked sense
of humor though he often used loki as
bait himself as part of their get help
ruse in which they faked distress to
escape
trouble you can help please my brother
is dying get help help him
classic
the brothers truly loved each other but
loki believed their father favored thor
which caused bitter jealousy and
resentment loki's feelings were
seemingly confirmed by odin's words to
him and his brother when they were young
only one of you can ascend to the throne
but both of you
were born to be kings
loki knew full well owed an intended
thor to succeed him on that throne still
loki remained close to his family
particularly his mother frigga he shared
a deep love and bond with her especially
as it was she who taught him sorcery his
respect and devotion to her didn't stop
him from engaging in troublesome pranks
though like when he visited midgard as
db cooper turned thor into a frog and
cut off a lock of sif's hair
after many years odin finally becomes
ready to hand the throne over to one of
his sons as seen in 2011's thor loki's
greatest fear is made a reality thor is
chosen over him unbeknownst to nearly
everyone loki makes a deal with the
frost giants of jotunheim providing them
with an entrance into asgard as thor's
coronation begins while odin is able to
thwart the invasion with the use of the
destroyer loki manages to goad his
brother into a reckless attack on
jotunheim without their father's
approval it's all part of a plan to get
thor out of his father's good graces
after loki learns of his true parentage
he feels betrayed by odin for keeping
such secrets and enraged by the fact
that he's been used as a pawn to unite
the nine realms because no matter how
much you claim to love me
you're gonna have a frost giant sitting
on the throne of asgard
incensed he seizes the throne and plots
with the frost giants to have odin
killed but upon returning from earth and
after learning of his brother's schemes
thor confronts loki and eventually
defeats him loki falls off the rainbow
bridge to parts unknown
after this loki finds himself working
for thanos who has begun a quest to
collect the six legendary infinity
stones loki is given a scepter powered
by the mine stone and tasks him with
collecting the tesseract a cosmic cube
that contains the space stone in
exchange loki will get to rule earth
with the help of the chittari army after
loki steals the tesseract however thor
tracks him down with the help of captain
america and iron man he apprehends loki
and brings him into the custody of nick
fury and shield a new team is assembled
to stop loki but the god of mischief is
prepared and devises the plan to turn
them against one another it almost works
but not quite the newly minted avengers
are too mighty even for loki and
ultimately prevail in the end loki is
taken into custody by thor and returned
to his own realm to face asgardian
justice he not only fails thanos he
allows two infinity stones to fall into
human hands what happened silver tongue
turned the
lead returned to asgard loki stands
before odin in judgment for his actions
on earth the all-father spares his life
but only because frigga pleased on her
wayward son's behalf loki is sentenced
to eternal imprisonment in the dungeons
beneath the royal palace while he
endures his confinement wars raged
throughout the nine realms thanks to the
destruction of the bifrost bridge but
when the dark elves attack asgard
killing frigga loki is distraught and
when they proceed to escape asgard loki
gets his chance to be set free loki is
asked to help thor in a bid for
vengeance on the dark elves and offered
an attractive deal he will gain freedom
from his eternal sentence should they
succeed as part of a daring plan loki
uses a devious illusion to fool malekith
and then fakes his own death
unwilling to risk losing his newfound
liberty and seeing a unique opportunity
in his present circumstances the god of
mischief confuses odin with another
illusion and sends him to midgard in
odin's form loki finally takes what he
believes is his rightful place as king
of asgard when thor comes to him even he
is fooled by the deception allowing loki
to grant him freedom to explore the nine
realms he knows thor's love of adventure
will keep him far from asgard
unfortunately after thor defeats the
demon serta and brings his crown back to
asgard he becomes suspicious of odin who
rules their ancestral home with casual
decadence exposed loki takes thor to
midgard to see their father who is near
death after odin's last breath is
exhaled hella the goddess of death and
the brothers hidden sister is unleashed
thor and loki attempt to get away
through heimdall's rainbow bridge but
hella manages to throw them off course
which lands them both on a far off
planet called sakhar
loki finds himself in the presence of an
immortal being called the grand master
the ruler of sakhar charming his way
into the grand master's good graces loki
becomes a friend and confidant to the
cosmic being things change when in an
odd bit of time displacement thor lands
on zakar some weeks after loki and finds
himself fighting in the contest of
champions what's more he's matched up
against none other than bruce banner the
incredible hulk after battling the hulk
before the roaring crowd thor begins
planning a rebellion so he can return to
asgard to defeat hella and save their
world loki refuses to join him feeling
it'll be a futile maneuver but then the
former asgardian warrior known as
valkyrie captures loki to prevent him
from exposing thor's escape he helps
them break free of the grand master but
is left behind when he predictably
attempts to betray him
dear brother becoming predictable
i trust you you betray me round and
round in circles we go
later loki goes on to have a change of
heart and convinces the rebels to travel
to asgard with their help he hopes to
join thor and valkyrie in their attempt
to defeat hela and save their realm from
total annihilation though the group
fights valiantly it becomes clear that
defeating hela means destroying asgard
the decision is made to abandon the
glittering realm and take the asgardians
into the stars to search for a new home
at the outset of avengers infinity war
loki is aboard the asgardian refugee
ship where he and thor have set a course
for earth but just as loki expresses
apprehension about how he might be
received there given his attempt to
conquer the planet years prior the ship
is attacked by thanos vessel audiences
aren't privy to the violent fight to
defend the ship only witnessing its
direct aftermath thanos's black order
stepping over the asgardian dead who
litter the deck of their ship loki and
thor have been left alive and when
thanos finally makes an appearance he
demands to know the location of the
tesseract that houses the space stone in
an attempt to get close enough to the
mad titan to strike a killing blow loki
produces the cube and offers it freely
along with his allegiance but thanos
sees through loki's ruse as thor watches
helplessly thanos grips loki by the
throat and snaps his neck killing him
once and for all
after countless ages of tormenting
asgard fighting alongside his brother
and exploring the mysteries of magic
loki son of asgard god of mischief
brother of thor
is dead at the hands of an interstellar
tyrant
let's back up a bit to the events of
2012's the avengers when loki attempts
to use the mind stone and a chitari army
to conquer earth there a group of
avengers from some 10 years in the
future arrive via a time machine devised
by tony stark using hank pym's quantum
technology in their timeline out of
avengers end game thanos has eliminated
half of all life in the universe they're
embarking on a risky plan to steal the
infinity stones from the past to undo
the damage of their future while the
original plan is to pluck the stones
from the timeline and return them
without anyone ever noticing things go
quickly awry which creates an entirely
new timeline while they attempt to steal
the tesseract after loki's defeat in new
york an ill-timed interruption by the
hulk comically fumbles the cube leaving
it at the god of mischief's feet
creating a new branching timeline loki
grabs the cube and uses its portal
powers to escape thor's custody in the
prime timeline thor takes him back to
asgard to stand before odin's judgment
in this new one the future is unwritten
i really don't see what all the fuss is
about
freed from the avengers keeping loki
finds himself transported to a vast
desert home to people who don't seem to
recognize him after a few confused
moments this errant loki is located and
scooped up by the time variance
authority an extra dimensional
organization that monitors and
eliminates alternate timelines loki's
theft of the tesseract and its branching
reality is not part of their sacred
timeline which means the tva is intent
on pruning him brought before one of
their best agents mobius m mobius loki
is given a glimpse of the original
timeline's future he sees his mother's
death during the dark elves invasion of
asgard odin's quiet passing the amends
he makes with his brother and even his
own demise at thanos's hands mobius then
offers loki a deal in exchange for his
help in tracking down yet another loki
variant who is apparently wreaking havoc
in the time stream he'll be saved from
pruning with few other options available
loki agrees
after a complicated hunt through history
loki discovers his troublesome variant
is a woman named sylvie who is like him
the adopted child of odin and frigga in
another reality but sylvie becomes the
target of the time variants authority in
her youth and was accordingly captured
and scheduled for pruning sylvie managed
to steal a tva 10-pad device and get
away however she's remained on the run
ever since over the course of her long
existence she has learned that the tva
isn't exactly what it appears to be and
neither are the so-called time keepers
loki is fascinated and even charmed by
sylvie curious what secrets she knows
desperate to escape the tva and
experiencing sheer affection he joins
her on her quest initially sylvie does
not want loki's help and even attempts
to kill him on more than one occasion no
less but the pair are eventually stuck
together on a doomed world and bond over
their shared experiences now true allies
they set out to reach the realm at the
end of time in the hopes of uncovering
the tva's deepest darkest secret
running out of options loki and sylvie
end up in a region called the void where
variants are sent after pruning there
they meet several different variants of
loki including an alligator loki a kid
loki and a middle-aged loki
always so perceptive
about everyone but yourself together
they battle a giant beast known as
aliyah who watches over the void and
serves as the gatekeeper of the citadel
at the end of time once they are
victorious loki and sylvie are able to
get through to the citadel and confront
the supreme being known only as he who
remains the mysterious he who remains
reveals himself to be a man from the
distant future he discovered the
multiverse and many variants of himself
which set off the multiversal war after
emerging victorious he who remains set
up the citadel and created the tva to
ensure no such war could ever happen
again he offers loki and sylvie a simple
choice take over the tva and guard the
sacred timeline in his stead or kill him
and unleash the multiverse and countless
evil versions of himself who seek
nothing less than total domination over
all reality while loki is unsure sylvie
is convinced it's all a lie
why aren't we saying this the same way
she stabs he who remains through the
heart killing him and opening up a new
multiversal era of the mcu
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite mcu stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]